inna Shevchenko is the leader of the
international women's movement FEMEN a
writer a speaker and a fearless free
speech advocate inna welcome to the show
hello hi thank you for invitation yeah
for a long I should say well I'm really
glad that we connected I've known about
your work for a while and then I saw a
piece that you wrote in the
International Business Times last week
about the regressive left and the racist
right and that basically most of us are
in between and that's very much what
what we've been talking about here on
this show so I thought it would be a
perfect time to talk to you so you're
you're in Austria right now is that
right I'm right now in Austria yes yes
right can I ask what you're doing there
or is this a top-secret mission
yeah no it's I'm here for a conference
about free speech of course I hope that
this time it will not be interrupted by
a terrorist we will be speaking and
enjoy this topic discussing this topic
all right well we're gonna talk about
some of the interruptions that you've
had by terrorists when you're giving
talks on free speech but first let's do
a little bit on your biography because I
think it's pretty amazing I mentioned at
the top of the show you were born in
Ukraine not the Ukraine you were born in
Ukraine the same year that the Soviet
Union fell and I think that had a lot to
do with sort of your your path right now
because of things that you saw in a sort
of newborn country so can you talk a
little bit about your history first well
right I was born the year my country was
born actually yeah and of course the
situation you know for me as a child for
me it was just just childhood but for
adults it was of course a rough reality
and then later I understood that I had a
rough childhood however you know for me
to make a home work under the candles
because all electricity in the city was
shot for the sake of economy you know we
didn't have we didn't have a national
currency and my parents were receiving
celery with sausages or with bread you
know and yeah I mean poverty I'm poverty
was poverty you know and
I think that this is not something
special for ya to tell you about it
because still until today many people
live in part in 25 years after Ukraine
well actually right now in this similar
situation and you know already my nephew
a small child who is 8 years old he
lives nearly a similar situation and has
similar childhood to what I had so
situation is not really changing and
progressing but of course it had a
really huge impact on me and I think on
all generation that was born after
collapse of USSR because we saw what we
saw that you know as adults were saying
our country was ruled by 450 idiots this
is I'm quoting yeah particularly yeah my
grandma and my mother they were calling
them well all adults were calling
politicians always you know there was
always this clear gap between society
and those 450 idiots again as they say
there was always a gap between
government and and actually citizens and
you could you know as a child and never
could imagine that there could be any
connection between those people between
this small group of people that we could
call 1% in 99% of population there was
always an impression as if we were
living in different countries I saw of
course you know I grew up in a very
traditional society where woman has to
work and well to have job and also of
course take care of everything at home
and even though my father was not a
particular patriarch but of course all
while my mother was housewife as well as
working full-time and in 90s during well
during this time of you know trying to
create a government in the country after
collapse of USSR parents had to work on
different jobs and my mother was working
on three different jobs and of course
taking care of us at
which of course gave an impression and
kind of you know yeah well yeah we had
the painted picture of what woman is
supposed to do and what her mission is
and what man is supposed to do and even
in such a hard economically time my
father was of course earning much more
and had access to more jobs and could
could yeah had possibility to find
different jobs more interesting than my
mother women really were doing two jobs
because they were working and they were
taking care of the home and the kids and
all that yeah and I yeah I think it's
incorrect to speak in the past because
as I already decided remains the reality
is still exactly the same and maybe
sometimes we have an illusion you know
expect in a different cover and we can
see more women who do not do that
however still majority of women live
that life and my mother still continues
to work in two different jobs today and
well she doesn't have children anymore
we are going right so I don't think you
think there is anything wrong with that
in and of itself you just sort of want
people to acknowledge the role of the
woman right what do you mean I don't
think well that they're doing that
they're doing both these things that
they it's not bad to take care of your
kids in and of itself right it's not bad
to take care of your kids but it's bad
if you're the only ones supposed to take
care of your kids right so the role the
role well yeah exactly that you have to
follow the role and you have no choice
and I think I think there's a lot of
things that are wrong in this in this
concept and in this reality and
therefore we yeah we started our
movement in Ukraine as a women's
movement feminist movement even though
at the beginning I should confess when
we started our activity we didn't really
had a clear understanding what feminism
was about because for example to give
you yet to give you an example I was
studying in the best university of
Ukraine I was studying journalism and in
four years of my studies I never had
even even one hour lecture on what
feminism is well I didn't even hear the
definition of such
ideology because that was something
which is not close to Eastern European
society again where women have to be at
home and take care of her of family but
not going to street and demand their
rights actually it's not concerning only
women's rights but generally I grew up
in the country where people do not until
2008 a 2004 sorry
at the moment of Orange Revolution the
first revolution that happened in the
history of independent Ukraine until
that moment people didn't have a you
know to protest was a you know an
activity of a bad taste move aigoo you
know it was something that you wouldn't
do it was something that you would do
only to probably earn money because
political parties in Ukraine pay you for
standing with their flags and the street
and protesting supporting one or another
politician so when we started our
activity we were of course accused -
accused for being paid by someone and
being political project or also being
named by our parents or relatives who
knew that we don't get money for that we
would just simply named either witches
or psychologically sick girls right okay
so I don't want to jump too far ahead
yet so we're gonna we're gonna go into
we're gonna go into all that but just to
sort of wrap up the Ukraine part because
I think a lot you know there's so much
happening with Ukraine and as you said
it is a young country it's only 25 years
old in terms of independence what do you
make of what's happening in Ukraine now
because it sort of seems like the the
quest for true independence in a way has
failed because Russia is is back in
Ukraine right so is do you feel like
you're part that Ukraine is really an
independent state at this point
well Ukraine is an independent state and
I think that nobody should question it
well of course
Putin questions right I mean Russia's
questioning it yeah but Ukraine is an
independent state of course even though
our territories were already taking an
occupied like Crimea work was recently
occupied and Ukraine lost it
right now and still there is a eastern
part of Ukraine occupied by Russian
military troops and I will say it
bravely I will claim that their Russian
troops as it was proven well Ukraine is
an independent state which is definitely
at the stage of its development and
creation and you know choosing the the
path while 99 percent of population
today are screaming for euro-integration
and for wish to join European Union or a
dream because I think it's quite a dream
not a possibility yet there was still
the garment the one that I mentioned
about 450 just remain they were they
remained those people because well I
should say that the problem of my
country what my country the country
where I was born because I don't feel
like I have a country I think that the
problem of this country is that for 25
years at least I observe the same faces
in the parliament I hear the same names
of politicians it's the country is ruled
by the same if you want you know mafia
oligarch unions fractions and for
example today's president poroshenko who
is you know supposed to be and he claims
to be the one who is for your
integration he was a Minister of Foreign
Affairs in the cabinet in a parliament
of President Yanukovych who was recently
the dictator against who people went out
recently at the square in Maidan in Kiev
so definitely I should say that this
revolution you know I think that it's
it's intellectually unfair and wrong to
think that after people go out and
assert that revolution is when people go
out in the street well no it's it's
beginning of it it's it's beginning of
the process and I think that the protest
started in 2004 the first orange
revolution ten years after people again
went out in the street because the
changes didn't happen today again many
people are deceived because they don't
see rapid changes but
I think that it's mistaken and wrong to
expect changes right away I think that I
think that Ukraine will have to will
have to have few more revolutions yeah
so speaking of that do you do you think
what is the average person in Ukraine
feel about how the rest of the world
views them now because I sense that the
people of Ukraine want more help from
the West and that you know in America we
talk about it you know we talked about
it for like the two weeks that Putin was
moving troops in or whatever it was
there was a two week window where we
talked about it now it just we just
completely forget about it is there a
disappointment on behalf of the people
sort of how the the world has reacted to
what's happened there well of course yes
there is a disappointment because you
know people feel that people know that
their garments is actually unable to do
something to change something and since
people give you know from this Square in
Maidan they were giving the messages to
the world of course they do expect from
other states more powerful so-called
Democratic who already reached a certain
level who could help and support and
especially those who supported verbally
but do not support support practically
of course many people are as I said
deceived and disappointed today and even
some come to the point when they say
that with Yanukovych was the dictator it
was better because at least we had what
to eat and he did his government didn't
touch yeah so so last thought on this
and then we're gonna move on to some of
the feminism stuff I mean wasn't and
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
didn't Ukraine have nukes which they
gave up as part of that they would get
NATO protection once they were an
independent nation and basically that
just didn't happen right so they sort of
gave up their protection though the
weapons that would have protected them
and then they get this invasion or
whatever you want to call it from Russia
and now the other countries right there
are doing nothing we're doing nothing so
it was it was really like an unfortunate
decision I suppose well I mean if we
will go right now in discussing about
decision or net so I think it will be
too complicated
or because well there are a lot of sides
of this question but yes this is what
happened and of course many people today
thinking back and think that what kind
of mistakes were done but at that moment
it seemed to be a very correct decision
because you know nobody could expect
that Putin would suddenly decide to
occupy the territories and prove the
world that he is even bigger dictator
than already the world perceive him as
you